so we have to talk about your fur babies
um i just met izzy says frankie right
frankie i'm gonna go get him for you
frankie come here come say hi
i was like i met him before the
interview and i just uh he's so cute he
should be on camera this
is he is the case frankie say hi hi
frankie
goodness look at it he's got a little
floppy ear right here
oh you've kind of become famous with
this dog because
we see pictures of y'all everywhere so
is that for the
shelter pet project that you do exactly
yeah so um i rescue both
um frankie and his older brother chance
um
and uh and so i do a lot of work with
the shelter pet project which is
also with the humane society and
maddie's fun and the ad council
and uh we tried to you know
get the word out that shelter pets are
awesome so that people
aren't always going to breeders and um
to pet stores
and that they're you know we're trying
to change the stigma of what a shelter
pet is
yeah do you sing songs to them um
because you said you're not a singer but
i heard you sing
i do sing songs um because you know like
i do that i do like let me see i'm gonna
get i'll show you i'll tell you my
my franky one well chance i can get a
chance
oh my god you're like houdini you just
appeared in another door
wait here i'm gonna say hi to chance
oh and look king charles cavaliere is
that yeah and he's the rescue too and
that was actually what i was going to
say is that
you know people think that a lot of
times from that shelter pets are aren't
you know they're like oh i really want
to get this like certain breed or i
really want like you know
and he's um he was rescued from a puppy
mill and so he's purebred
so chance i have a song for him and it
goes okay
my name is chance
my name is chance
because even in the middle of his own
song he gets tired
this is taking forever right here yeah
this is frankie because you got that
floppy ear
yes it's like this like that great
flop wait ready flop flop floppy ears i
got some flop floppy ears
what flop flop floppy ears i got some
flop floppy ears okay now
flap [ __ ] flippy flop frankie flop the
flow
that's it oh my god i love you so much
yeah i have another one too i just want
to sing just because i love it
work it out work it out work it out work
it out flop
flop work it out work it out work it out
work it out just just fluff it up
frankie
just just flop it up frankie i love you
i wish this is the time i wish pets
could talk
and like if they were like they were
like yeah
seeing a girl or they're like she's
doing it again
oh if she could only hear the songs we
sing about her
yeah those are the ones yeah secret life
of pets those movies are so great for
kids
so um all this work with animals has
inspired you to start working with a new
charity right tell me what you're doing
yeah so there's this charity um called
stay home and foster
and uh you know they've already been
doing a great job of trying to get
people to
to foster animals and um and it really
was important when
covet happened and the lockdown happened
and when that happened a lot of shelters
uh were having to euthanize animals
because they couldn't take care of them
and
also at the same time people needed
animals in their lives you know
as you know like you know it it does
something different for you and your
kids like when you have an animal there
and especially phenomenal right yeah
a companion yeah yeah and so um
so i partnered with uh stay home and
foster myself and wag
and to promote this this cause and this
initiative for them
and it was so great because we had 85
000 people sign up
um in just such a short period of time
to foster pets across our country
and it really showed us that you know
there is a really big need
for um for fostering and for um and for
us to create something even bigger
something that's more evergreen that uh
really connects everything that people
you know will need when it comes to like
whether it's um
you know uh getting more advice on how
to train your dogs
and um and where to you know find a dog
in which shelter or
rescue place you can trust so um with
stay home and foster we are actually
doing
this next um phase of it now which i'm
really excited about
um which is called fido foster or feline
foster
um and basically we're trying to create
um a community that connects all the
shelters in our country
and be one place that people can go to
to go i haven't said this to people
because
yes because i'm like even how you said
like when people want something specific
like oh i got this dog because i wanted
this
that dog probably exists it's just in
wisconsin you don't know like
you know so i have said this this is
such a great idea yeah i mean you need
somewhere that you can you can trust and
and it's also somewhere that um goes
beyond just
giving you the dog it's you know um
anything with nutrition actually right
now since the beginning covet i was like
yeah i got to do something with my
my time and i didn't feel like writing
scripts like everybody was doing and
they're like we're going to come out
with eight scripts and it's
i can't but what i got into was um
getting my pet nutritionist license on
online i know it's been really great and
so
things like with feline and fighter
foster you know you can go on and say
like
what are the things that we shouldn't be
giving our dogs and what are the things
that we should be giving them
so yeah so with fido and feline foster
we are trying to create
um a real um strong community that will
that will last
you know and that is somewhere that
everybody can can trust and
go and be able to help save these
animals and you know
and add a little furry friend to their
family yeah because it means it's
life-changing
when it i mean just my kids with my dog
henry like they
they love henry it's such a security
blanket it's such a
friend like it's all these things it's a
great what animals do for households i
believe but
yeah subscribe to my channel subscribe
to my channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel
please don't make me keep going